doug can you um explain to us the
process by which you called up uh walker
and i guess we've just announced that
you can sign up the goalie controllers
yeah since we talked last week i feel
like dr fochi talking to you guys once a
week about medical issues here with our
minor league team inactive because of
covid we have uh 13 employees down there
with code with eight players
so when you look at
look at our current roster right now of
eligible players
that could play hockey 25 percent of our
groups has covered right now
it's mid-december in the national hockey
league a time when teams start to reveal
their true character
and with just two weeks until their
upcoming game outdoors at target field
both the minnesota wild and st louis
blues spend the week overcoming
obstacles and building confidence
hit by a hard wave of covid the blues
managed to strike back against the
florida panthers
while the wild see the return of their
captain
and take their winning ways out west as
we continue on the road to the 2022 nhl
winter classic
[Music]
in the nhl
injuries are part of the journey
but this week the saint louis blues find
themselves in a rather unique position
they're down nine players and tonight
against the detroit red wings will need
to rely on one who hasn't played an nhl
game in seven months
australian nathan walker
this is my third year with the
organization now and i like to think i
work pretty hard and i think that feeds
into my game
yeah i've been very happy and proud for
the players having different guys step
up and i think everyone pulls for guys
like walk because they have a great
attitude in training camp they do
everything they can do we're learning as
we go it's a different twist that we
didn't think we'd be dealing with at
this time of the year
here now the blues get it in front shot
they scar
walker his first game up
and the aussie is giving the ball as a
[Applause]
and walker he comes up from springfield
with his first ever hat trick in the
national hockey league and then you've
got to head chuck it at your radio
[Applause]
over the course of my career my life
with hockey my family and i we've made a
lot of sacrifices it's kind of nice when
this kind of happens
[Applause]
[Music]
hello good job boys couple honor
dimensions
ducky
[Applause]
on to the next
[Applause]
with two short weeks until the winter
classic the minnesota wild remain in
first place in the central division
and as the city prepares for the main
event assistant captain marcus felino
and his wife natasha prepare to host
their family
[Music]
we're really excited for the winter
classic we're going to be having all of
my family my in-laws are coming my
father-in-law my sister-in-laws are
going to be here it's a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to be a
part of it
it's gonna be such a fun atmosphere so
you know a lot of people my family have
helped me get to the nhl so we want to
put on a show that night and make sure
everyone's gonna have fun with it
hug
oh so nice
optional skate days are the best days
i guess he's a veteran now which is kind
of crazy to think too he usually takes
the option whereas before he never did
and he would always go in no matter what
so it's nice that he'll take it and
he'll stay home or take the daughter in
and do like a spa day as he likes to
call it
[Music]
all right you ready
you need bullets have your door
you remember this place eh see daddy's
stall right over there
all right what do you say we go in the
pool
being a dad has probably been one of the
best things that's ever happened to me
in my life
[Music]
it's nice and warm come on no you want
to jump in off the side
[Music]
it means a lot to me to bring your
daughter in knowing that you know she's
so excited inside she loved every minute
of being at the rink
[Music]
you know days like this where you're
able to bring in one of your daughters
into the rink and just really embrace
kind of what i do and and have you know
your daughter along for a ride bring
your kid to work day it's just a really
special feeling
all right let's do it you're tired
okay we'll keep quiet
[Music]
before the week culminates the minnesota
win streak reaches eight
[Applause]
but it ends with two tough losses on the
road
[Applause]
while the blues beat montreal to take
their third straight
then drop one in overtime to anaheim
troy terry on a penalty shot as of now
just four points separate the teams atop
the central division as they continue on
the road to the nhl winter classic
you